[Music]
all right let's go to caitlin in
colorado springs hey caitlin what's
going on
hi
how are you
um you know hanging in there hanging in
there good deal
all right so how are you hanging in
there how can i help
so my sister is high functioning autism
and she has been in and out of an
abusive relationship for the past three
years how old is she um
she's 27 27
mentally probably around 18 ish
um she just found out that she is
pregnant by this man and he chose his
live-in girlfriend over her
and so he she has asked me to adopt her
child
and i don't know how to even go about
processing this
whoo
man
wow welcome to it right
yeah yikes
um so there's a lot here
um
he doesn't have to
be married to her legally but he doesn't
get to opt out of this baby's life right
yeah well i guess if you adopted this
baby you would be taking that
responsibility from him is he signing
over custody
um
it's so he has a child by another
woman and he fought aggressively for
that child and so i'm guessing
it would be a joint custody situation
between
me my husband and him
yeah are they interesting too
yeah so i'm asking some questions i've
got real strong feelings about this but
um
tell me about your sister she's
high-functioning autistic does she have
is she full full and like full-time
employment
um no she hasn't held the job for three
years she'll start for two weeks and get
overwhelmed and quit okay is she seeking
any sort of support care
or
no
no okay um
will she or just will she not
she doesn't think there's anything wrong
with her so she refuses to seek any sort
of care even though i know she would be
a candidate for any sort of governmental
support or i mean she needs mental
health support she needs it all but she
refuses to admit it
is this pregnancy a wake-up call to her
or no
no she's pretending it's not happening
other than asking me to adopt a child
i don't often
on this show especially say the words
i've never heard this situation before
but i've never heard this situation
before katie
um
so
how did the conversation come up with
her coming to you
she called me crying
saying it's it's the test is positive so
um more of the situation is that she was
helping watch his daughter even though
his live-in girlfriend was there as well
i didn't fully understand the situation
and then he asked her to cut the birth
control out of her arm um
the one the rod that goes in and so she
did
and her doctor specifically told her
you're going to get pregnant because
you're sleeping with him
and then with her with his living
girlfriend in the place
yeah
yeah she doesn't know about any of this
she doesn't know his living girlfriend
lives there
no their living girlfriend doesn't know
about anything with my sisters but
they're sleeping together or any of that
i just have one word awesome
yeah
wow
okay and so she calls me surprised but
she's pregnant of course
is she surprised
cognitively like is this a surprise to
her or is she surprised that she got
caught you know what i mean that she got
caught is is her
cognitive capacity one that she doesn't
is unable to put
one plus one equals two that if i cut
this
birth control
out of my arm
and i have unprotected sex with this guy
i'm gonna get pregnant is she unable to
make that algorithm work or is she being
an immature young person and living in
denial
i think it's more of the denial
okay
if how old are you
i'm 31 31 okay where's mom in this
situation
oh she's done she's so tired of dealing
with my sister
my dad too yeah okay
um
can she hear
can your sister hear a family
conversation
probably not no
okay
so i'm gonna strongly recommend you do
not adopt this kid
okay
um i have an explanation do what
do you have an explanation as to why um
it's not your kid
and i say that meaning it's his
kid
and there's i've never heard of a joint
custody where he doesn't really want to
have
he doesn't really want to have custody
he doesn't want to be with her but he's
going to work out some joint arrangement
with you all too i mean that's just how
that works
if you adopt this kid he signs off that
he's out she signs off that she's out
and this is y'all's kid
and then you have a sister with mental
health challenges that are i mean here's
the thing a hurricane landed in your
home and you all got to deal with it
correct
but sort of because it's her home
and my guess is you all have been
cleaning up this you say your parents
were just tired i heard it in your voice
it wasn't just words like you they are
exhausted
and they've been dealing with this
forever
and here it is now it's grandkid time
now it's niece or nephew time for you
and
if he came everybody has to have a
grown-up conversation what's going to
happen
and if he was to say i will sign this
child over i don't want this kid i don't
want anything to do with this kid
and she said i'm going to sign this over
and i'm gonna move in with you guys for
the next seven months and deal with this
then that's another thing
and then maybe you and your husband are
the most altruistic extraordinary people
on the planet you adopt this kid
and she's got some sort of
peripheral relationship but y'all hold
boundaries and it's just gonna be a
tough road to hoe for the next 20 years
and that may be a very realistic reality
for you
but there i don't there's no such thing
as a joint custody where you adopt a kid
but dad's involved like there's no
three-way custody kind of thing it's his
baby yeah okay yeah and so what i would
do is call him
do you have a relationship with him can
you talk to him
i have his number i've met him a few
times it'd anger her to no end if i
contacted him without her knowledge well
she's gonna have to be a part of the
conversation too
because the courts are gonna recognize
her as an adult unless she gets unless
you call on her and get a psych
evaluation that says she is unfit
yeah and then they can terminate
parental rights in utero
and then the second that baby is born it
goes to a family member but they're
gonna have to do a psych work up on it
it's i mean it's world war three but
you're in it right and she's gonna fight
you and hate you and all of those things
or she may be totally at peace
what you and your husband have to come
to terms with and you and your mom and
your dad have to come to terms with
is
there's a baby here that's caught up in
the middle of this
yeah and you've got your exhaustion with
your sister your anger with your sister
your we've been telling you her this for
30 years with your sister
and that's on one side of the equation
the other side is there's a baby here
and my guess is the fact that you're
calling me you're not the kind of person
just
to let that ride you know what i mean
great exactly do you want to adopt this
kid
i i mean i have two of my own and we
were done
and now that there's this infant out
there that didn't do any of this like i
can't just let it go into foster care or
with this dad that is an abusive man
like
i
i have this um
savior complex i think honestly well
there's a savior complex and then
there's
that baby needs a home
and those are two different things you
grew up in the home of a sister with
special needs
so
everyone who grows up in the home of a
kid with special needs is either all the
way out or they are looking for people
to help that's just that's that's the
that's the you get to see a ringside
seat to an empathetic life right so
you're there
um
here's the only way i see this thing
playing out you have to sit down with
her and with him
and say she's pregnant we will take this
baby but everybody signs off
okay and
you gotta go with an attorney and
through court and get it all documented
out that he doesn't loot back on you and
he probably still will loot back on you
she will loot back on you just know
you're in it
okay and it's gonna be a mess which
means you and your husband have to be
anchored tightly together you have to
know how far you're gonna go on this
deal you're gonna have to make sure
you're talking to a pastor or to
a marriage counselor as y'all walk
through this because your picture of
what your life is going to be is
different now
yeah and my gut tells me you've always
known something like this was coming
or you've always had in the back of your
head she'll move in with us at some
point or we're going to have to deal
like you've always had that back there
is that fair
yeah it was something drugs or something
we knew something was gonna happen right
yeah
and
that's where we are
and so what this situation desperately
needs is
one or two or three or four strong
adults
who are gonna cut through the
she's not gonna like me she's gonna be
mad at me i don't care
now there's a baby involved
my niece or my nephew's involved and
your parents are tired sorry i get that
but we're all in it now
and i know this guy's
a complete and total scumbag but it's
his kid
yeah and if he wants to say this is my
baby
um he gets to do that legally
and
that's gonna be that's gonna be
something y'all have to grieve together
until you know about abuse and whatnot
then you're gonna file on him and then
you'll end up with this child anyway
right
right yep
i think that's what i'm trying to avoid
in the situation too if i can is to not
have to go in and rescue
those horrible situations right
i'm so sorry you're in the middle of
this caitlyn
yeah it's rough it's
new too fresh you know yeah how far
along is your sister
uh six weeks
okay six weeks
yeah okay
yeah so you know you've been down the
stroll there's a lot that can happen
between now and
you know
eight and a half months from now nine
months from now yeah
um yeah i definitely can
so here's what i do you live is your
sister live around y'all
about an hour away okay is she open to
coffee meetings is she open to
dinner with you once a week or something
like that or is that impossible
no she is yeah she's really involved in
my kid's life like she's great as a
nanny and a babysitter just not as a
parent okay she's very involved in our
lives
so it sounds like
she's high functioning and really smart
and is really loving and can turn it
down when it is convenient is that fair
or is that is that yeah am i not being
kind
no that's true she can um it's just when
she decides to and if she doesn't allow
the consistent
i don't i don't really know how to
describe it like if you see a
non-high-functioning autism person like
rocking in the corners that's kind of
what happens in her mind when she gets
overwhelmed by a decision okay she just
can't settle
okay
and when you walk alongside her is she
able to stay anchored a little bit
a little okay but then she also needs
someone to tell her what needs to happen
okay that's where i was actually aiming
which is you and your husband sit down
and say what are our boundaries here how
far will we go what will we do and that
will be everything from will she move in
with us when she's three months pregnant
and for the next six months or will we
financially support this this pregnancy
or
um and her nutrition and her are you
gonna go with her on her um
obgyn visits i mean how far are we going
to go here and make sure you all write
that down we are on the same page you
and me and give each other permission to
shift he may come to you a couple weeks
from now and say i just can't do it or
come to you a few weeks from now and say
we're gonna we're gonna go to hell and
back to get this kid right whatever that
i mean y'all may change as you go right
and then make sh write down
how you're gonna support and love her
not fix it and solve this problem this
problem is i mean this is what this is
but letting her know
i'm gonna love you through this and
handing her a sheet of paper that says
here's how i'm gonna support you i'm
gonna come to your doctor visits you're
welcome at my house at any time
if i'm gonna adopt this baby this is
what this will look like
if i see that you're doing drugs i'm
going to call the police i'm going to
call child protective services
immediately
and that may freak her out but i want
her to hold a piece of paper and it says
here and maybe the title of it is here's
how big sister is going to love you
yeah okay and you've been through two of
these and make sure that you know i mean
it can set up as a very caring next step
um and be really direct with her about i
know that we all both know that when
things get hard
um
you shut down
and so i want here's here's our when we
start to shut down here's what we're
gonna do and i'm gonna be there for you
or i'm not gonna be there for whatever
your boundaries are
and then you need to let her know that
we're gonna have to if you want me to
adopt this baby and again she may have
just found out and freaked out and told
you that and then
a month from now she's gonna want to
raise this kid so the option to bait to
adopt this child maybe zero maybe none
you never know right
um but it's boundaries direct
conversation and all of this ends up
with a conversation with the four of you
him her and you and your husband if this
adoption's gonna actually go through
whoo that baby's lucky to have you your
sister's lucky to have you and i know
that loving and being connected to
somebody who has
cognitive challenges who has atypical
um learning challenges who's autistic
who has any number of challenges i know
it's hard and it's exhausting and so
thank you for loving her even when it's
so so so hard
um there is no when it comes to adoption
there is no
hey we'll all just figure this out live
nope
there's got to be lawyers involved
there's going to be clear things
involved there's got to be
boundaries and protections for this kid
otherwise this kid becomes a pawn in a
long game and the kid pays
price thank you for your heart thank you
for your connection